i
thought and and you know forgive me but
i think i'm with a lot of people that i
thought
as far as like who in the professional
fighting world
jake paul could have called out that it
was like really rather genius to say
i'll box ben askren yeah because of
course
your your strength is is with wrestling
um
and i mean it is [ __ ] pretty pretty
genius and
now having said that i think that that
really squarely makes you
really important in the equation because
you know if you're looking for
an advantage in boxing then like who
else do you have
other than ben askren who is a huge name
in combat sports
but like notoriously not for striking
there's not really anybody else i think
he could have got a percentage
yeah uh i mean i just like i'm doing
well in life so i wasn't
all that concerned about it um seemed
fair so i said yes
uh they were going they're really going
after dylan danis who's like mcgregor's
lackey
and he's got a pretty good social media
following but you know i did bring this
up with um
in the press conference jake was like a
child he wouldn't shut up and let me
talk
um i saw that yeah i watched some of
that too that's so bad so he's kind of
like a bully though and it's like
you know i was i was retired i was four
months three and a half months out of my
hip surgery
so i was not training at all so yeah
obviously he wasn't trying to pick the
toughest guy he could pick he was trying
to pick
the easiest guy which could give him
some legitimacy
right um and i think that's pretty
obvious for me to zoom out and just
see that you know for sure um and that
being said even being
the easiest guy he can pick i think it's
probably still
too tough of a guy i think he's going to
get in there and um
you know i think boxing is strange i've
been in i've been in boxing like three
months now the community's kind of
strange i think he's got these guys
around him who are just telling him that
he's the best in the world he's so good
and to the point where he's almost
started to believe it
and so when he gets in you know in front
of someone and they won't go away and
they're fighting back
he's going to start panicking he's not
really really know what to do can you
talk about your game plan at all
yeah worn out
you know because we've never seen him
take a punch and we know that
you've been hit and you keep going and
that's your advantage too is that like
you've been in the fire before yeah i
mean so
my my strategy would obviously be to get
close and make it a tough fight i'm not
gonna stand and try to have pretty
boxing
um get in there and make it ugly make it
dirty land kind of like the dirty boxing
clinch strikes that type of stuff and
yeah to
that point we've never seen him really
go very long we've never seen him
against someone good
we've never seen him get hit we've never
seen him get tired
so there's all these big big question
marks with him right like how is he
what's going to happen and listen i said
i i i was at freddie roaches and i boxed
with one really really good guy
i'm like dude i don't want to be in
there with that guy that guy's going to
[ __ ] kill me
like you know so if for some reason he
is like the best in the world it's gonna
be a long night for me
i just i think that's like really really
really unlikely
i think uh it's incredible that it's
such a mystery that we that we don't
know
and that's probably why it's gonna do so
well how's the training different
from this in in mma like how you're not
weight cutting or are you weight cut
like what
what's no yeah i'm not weight cutting
because it's like
hey you're going to find a youtuber it's
not like there's some legal i get to
pick what weight class i'm going to go
it's like hey
there's this one youtuber guy here's the
weight class do you want it or not
um so i'm finding it 190 i wrestled at
174 fought at 170 so yeah it's big for
me
um what are you normally walking around
out before
before you cut to 170 so usually when
i'm when i'm like working out in shape
183 to 185 um i said i was retired i had
my hip surgery you guys don't see this
badass scar
yeah dude we love scars
oh [ __ ] that's a long one so i got my
hip re done in september
so literally like when i want to say
that pay-per-view the tyson one that
you're talking about was
um late november like i literally
wasn't allowed to do anything for three
months like
nothing nothing and then at three months
i got to start riding a bike and that
that type of thing
and so when i first you know first
started training i was really happy
because i hadn't been allowed to do
anything for like four and a half months
yeah dude with um with jake having sort
of all these yes people around him
like in some ways does that help him
i've heard mike tyson talk about like
he's like i would have to almost be like
delusional to go in these fights and
just think i'm so good like he was like
i would purposely sort of
be delusional and like is is that
unrealistic belief in yourself in some
ways a benefit
um well i i would say i think yes it is
important to have those
type of thoughts when you're going to
competition because the last thing
you want in competition is to like doubt
yourself have anxiety
um i mean for you guys you guys came
from extreme sports so it's like
you don't be on top of the half pipe
saying oh my god i'm gonna freaking fall
i'm gonna
if you're thinking like that you're
probably gonna fall you know
right you either wanna have a clear mind
where you're not really thinking about
anything
uh and you're just focused solely on the
execution of the technique
uh or you know you wanna say i'm gonna
freaking crush this one of those two
things you know
um so uh to a little bit yes it's
semi-beneficial when you step in the
ring but the the real huge
issue uh becomes is
if that doesn't come true right then
what do you do yeah yeah
you gotta be able to back it up it works
it's a 24 minute fight and it's not
coming true
then what sure you know like those guys
can't fight for him
their cheers really aren't going to help
him in the fight like it might help him
get through training
but in a real fight it's got to be you
saying like
i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] go get this
guy like i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm tough
enough yeah it can't be them
they can't help you at that point yeah
dude you know what pisses me off
expensive sunglasses cause you're gonna
lose them anyway
so never pay more than 10 bucks for a
pair that's why i buy mine at the gas
station
except they don't ever have the kind
that i'm very particular about i like my
style
right so i made my own these are stevo
sunglasses
and they're only 9.99 at stevo.com
and we got them back in stock so don't
be squinting in the sun getting wrinkles
go to stevo.com and make your summer fly
with some stevo's sunglasses